the world produces enough plastic each
year to build 50 pyramids of giza
that's over 350 million tons of candy
wrappers PVC pipes and synthetic
t-shirts while most of it ends up in
landfills eight million tons of plastic
winds up in our oceans each year where
most of it finds its way into massive
garbage patches around the world and the
biggest of them all is called the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch if you picked up
each piece of plastic in the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch you'd carry away
about 1.8 trillion individual pieces
that's 10 times more plastic pieces than
there are stars in our Milky Way galaxy
and it would weigh a whopping 80
thousand tons equivalent to the weight
of three statues of Liberty half of the
entire patch is made of plastic fishing
nets lines and ropes which come from
intense fishing activity near the area
the other half is mostly hard plastics
and films like water bottles and plastic
wrap but don't let the name Great
Pacific Garbage Patch fool you it
doesn't look like a giant mountain of
trash at all it's actually scattered
over a region of ocean that's twice the
size of Texas according to some
estimates so if you wanted to pick up
every piece of plastic it would take you
121 days at a walking pace of 5
kilometers per hour to cover the entire
area though in reality there's no true
end since the Garbage Patch is
constantly ebbing and flowing with the
ocean currents but let's pretend we
could scoop it all up into one place
there'd be enough plastic to fill 100
Boeing 747 planes and the patch is only
getting bigger it's actually been
growing exponentially larger for nearly
70 years partly because once the plastic
is there it'll stick around for
centuries
those plastic fishing lines for example
will take 600 years to break down and
even after they break down the damage
doesn't stop there most end up as micro
plastics that are too small to see with
the naked eye but can make it into the
bellies of sea animals and ultimately
the humans that will eat those animals
worldwide
researchers have found ingested micro
plastics in every species of sea turtle
nearly 60 percent of whale species and
almost 60% of seabirds plus more plastic
is pouring into the world's oceans each
day in fact experts estimate that by of
the year 2050 the amount of plastic in
the oceans will outweigh all the world's
fish think about that the next time you
toss your water bottle in the trash
because the recycling is full
you
[Music]